the 600,000 anti bracelet protestors
have gathered to demand a second
referendum vote the march was organized
by the people's vote campaign who say
this protest could be the biggest anti
brexit action yet some people have
traveled from all around the country to
take part in the rally and a separate
probe brexit rally was held in Harrogate
in the north of England led by former UK
Pleader and Nigel Faraj British Prime
Minister Tracy May has dismissed calls
for a secondary referendum on brexit
however some MPs have voiced support for
the protests the UK voted to leave the
EU by a narrow margin in 2016 with the
deadline for London's official divorce
from Brussels set for March next year
well we'll discuss this further now with
Ben harris-kearney who's the chairman of
the conservative UK think-tank and the
Bo group thanks for coming on to the
programme Ben this protest that we've
seen has been described as the biggest
in the UK since the Iraqi war will the
government take notice now that I mean
we're looking at nearly 700,000 people
protesting and voicing their concerns
will the government take notice will
they allow the British public to have
their say on the final deal well firstly
those figures of 600,000 not what the
Metropolitan Police are saying that's
what the organizers of the process -
saying we know that tens of millions of
pounds have flooded in from people like
George Soros to fund these kinds of
things but until such a time as in
excess of seventeen point four million
people come out and protest I think we
can assume that Britain's largest
exercise in democracy in its history the
EU referendum still stands does that
mean you're dismissing the people who've
protested today because there's hundreds
absolutely yes because the democracy
doesn't work in that way the democracy
works on the basis of votes not on the
basis of how many people turn up to
certain protests I mean we had the the
last major outpouring of process in
London was actually during Donald
Trump's visit but all polls at the time
suggested that the majority of the
British people were supportive
the President of the United States being
able to visit the United Kingdom so and
it's unclear what these protests prove
they prove that if external
organizations and individuals like
George Soros plow millions of pounds
into a campaign you can get several
hundred thousand people to turn out but
as I say we've had an exercise in proper
democracy of vote which which occurred
just over two years ago and the majority
of the British people voted to leave the
European Union so in no way does any
protest Trump that and I think my
question to those who are calling for a
second referendum is exactly how often
do they wish to have a referendum on our
membership of the European Union every
year every six months every month I mean
it's ludicrous we've had the people's
vote the people voted and now it's time
for the government to get on with it
but these people protesting are saying
that they had the votes yes it was a
narrow win but they feel that they've
been lied to
been have they got any right to feel
like that do you think that's why
they're on the streets and you know for
you to dismiss those thousands and
thousands of voices is that fair to
those people well but those people and
and people like George Soros are
dismissing seventeen point four million
voices which as I say Trump any amount
of people that you turn out in a protest
which is not a democratic vote and what
I would say to people who feel they've
been lied to is that the circumstances
of the the EU referendum vote was held
was very clear we was to leave the
European Union to leave the single
market and to leave the customs union
and that's what brexit ears have
continued to campaign for we haven't had
a brexit government which David Cameron
called for when he left office we
haven't had a brexit ear Prime Minister
we haven't had a brexit ear cabinet and
70 percent of Parliament is made up of
people that voted for remain so in terms
of implementing what brexit e is voted
for we would very much like to do that
but we're not in government yeah and how
likely though is it and we have to
look at this very quickly Ben is it that
the UK will leave the EU without any
deal whatsoever because that wasn't part
of the promise was it well again as I
say brexit ears are not in government so
we are unable to deliver what what we
set out as our vision during the brexit
referendum we have a remain of prime
minister we have a 70% remain cabinet
and a 70% remain Parliament I do think
that needs to change but it won't change
before the article 50 deadline I think a
No Deal brexit is the most likely
because of that circumstance we haven't
been sending negotiators that believe in
brexit and that's what we need to do and
I think eventually we will get a brexit
supporting prime minister and a brexit
supporting cabinet but is yet to happen
you